hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll I don't want
to mess around a lot at the very
beginning of this one because you've
probably heard of today's guest who is
Sir Roger Penrose one of the most
important and interesting thinkers and
scientists of recent years of my
lifetime that's for sure
if you don't know Sir Roger Penrose as a
physicist you might know him as a writer
of popular level books the road to
reality the emperor's new mind and so
forth but he made his bones as it were
in the field of general relativity
Einstein's theory of gravity along with
Stephen Hawking he helped invent the
singularity theorems the idea that if
you get enough stuff in a region of
space general relativity says you can't
help but collapsing to a point of
infinite space-time curvature the Roger
Penrose has done many other things in
addition to that just as one example
early on in the podcast he mentions
doing some early work on the nature of
infinity in space-time and what he's
really referring to is the idea of a
Penrose diagram which general
relativists used to make a little
picture of an entire space-time roughly
speaking Penrose diagrams are as
important for people in general
relativity as Fineman diagrams are for
people doing particle physics and not
only that Roger Penrose has come up with
the Penrose triangle the Penrose process
for extracting energy from black holes
Penrose tilings twister theory the
cosmic censorship hypothesis many other
extraordinarily influential ideas in
general relativity and he doesn't stop
there with general relativity as you do
know if you're a fan of Penrose he's
been working in recent years with ideas
in quantum mechanics he has his own
basically idea about how wave functions
collapse in quantum theory and the
implications of those ideas for
consciousness and have that relates to
girdle's theorem and artificial
intelligence and all these big picture
ideas now in my mind the thing about
Roger Penrose is that he understands
four-dimensional curved space-time
better than any person alive so that's
what I chose to talk about in our
conversation mostly in this particular
podcast we do go on to other things we
talk about consciousness and quantum
mechanics for
last half-hour so we could have talked
about those four hours more but we both
had schedules to meet sorry about that
one thing I got a note is that we both
got stuck on the names of the three
people who were the authors on the
papers on blackhole the laws of
blackhole mechanics it's Jim Bardeen
whose name we forgot sorry Jim
who wrote papers with Stephen Hawking
and Brandon Carter about that topic now
talking to Roger Penrose the great thing
about him is he's fearless
he has enormously creative deep ideas
many of them have been incredibly
successful and influential many of them
are idiosyncratic many of them I don't
agree with you know I didn't agree with
his ideas about entropy back when I was
first learning cosmology I later
realized he was completely correct in
his picture of entropy in the early
universe and that had a huge impact on
my career so I'm always happy and
respectful talking to Roger Penrose
whether or not I agree with his ideas
you can decide whether or not you agree
or disagree with any of them in
particular what the point of the podcast
is is to give you information about what
the ideas are you're the one who's got
to make the decision about what to think
at the end of the day so this is an
extremely fun conversation it's a great
way to start off the year 2019 let me
just do quick - quick podcast
announcements of course you can always
support mindscape on either patreon or
just directly through PayPal go to the
webpage to find information about that
and like any podcaster we love getting
good reviews on iTunes and elsewhere so
we have a wonderful list of guests
coming up for the rest of 2019 but I
can't think of a better place to start
it off than talking with Sir Roger
Penrose about the nature of space-time
black holes and cosmology so let's go
[Music]
roger penrose welcome to the mindscape
podcast hello
now you've not only done a lot of
amazingly important scientific
intellectual work but on an amazing
variety of topics and so usually for the
podcast often for the podcast I like to
focus in on one I have the feeling that
my people will be upset if we don't hit
all the various high points of you know
cosmology quantum mechanics
consciousness so you know we can spend
three hours if you want but I'm gonna
try to you know get the get the main
things in there by thought
starting with space time would be a good
thing to do I mean this is where you
sort of you know made your bones early
early on it was it is it safe to say the
first big thing you published the first
major result was the singularity theorem
for black holes I think that's true I'm
trying to remember the order of which
things were done I had to physically
letter articles and one was on conformal
infinity how one represents radiation
gravitational radiation by squashing
infinity down to a place where you can
see it more or less and this is a nice
way of talking about things like
gravitational radiation electromagnetic
magnetic radiation and so on but then I
wrote this article in 1965 I think it
wasn't a 64 I think which was about
black holes except we didn't call them
then that at that time this was
gravitational collapse way going way
back to work done by Chandra Sekhar in
the 1930s when he was on the boat coming
to England
still I think 19 or something I can't
remember and he worked out that a white
dwarf star would have a certain maximum
mass and if it was more than that then
it would collapse basically right
Chandrasekhar limit let's just take her
limit to you is what was worked out at
that time the white dwarf stars being
very very concentrated so that the mass
of the Sun might be con
in something like the size of the earth
but these stars are certainly known the
companion of Sirius another such stars
so it was he said these are things that
were well-established but what
Chandrasekhar showed was if the mass was
above a certain amount which was a bit
more than the mass of the Sun half one
and a half times the mass of the Sun
then there was nothing would hold it
apart and it would collapse down and the
question is what happens to it and
Chandra was very sort of modest about
this and he is less speculating on what
happens
where is Eddington at the time was
thinking this is ridiculous that can't
happen
shuttle singer got a lot of pushback
right for this idea that their weak
gravitational collapse yes indeed he got
into about two trouble because well it's
a wild idea so I'm not surprised
actually shake it a little push this but
of course that didn't get down to a
black hole he just said well one is
enough speculating I suppose he had some
sort of idea that it might the mayor
well a lot of early work which people
say there was this and I forget people's
names on the right on the spur of the
moment anyway there's early workers
where people wondered what happened to a
very massive objects but in terrible
general relativity came along there
wasn't really an issue which was
problematic and it was in the 1939 when
Oppenheimer of atom bomb fame and a
student of his Snyder and they worked
out an exact model according to
Einstein's general theory of relativity
of a collapsing dust cloud and it was a
picture of a black hole that we have now
but a lot of people were a bit
suspicious of whether that was really
what you'd expect because well there
were two things one is the dust cloud
was material that had no pressure so it
wouldn't push itself apart at all and it
would fall into the middle and it
wouldn't stop itself from pressure the
other point was the Marvel was exactly
spherically symmetrical
exactly the same all the way around and
so that the matter as it collapse
inwards would be aimed right at the
central point and so the fact that you
got infinite density there was not
perhaps surprising and people thought
well maybe if it was irregular it would
fall in and and maybe swish around a bit
and then comes swirling out right they
thought this was an artifact was it
maybe some special thing but it's not
usually what you'd expect that's right I
think there was argument about it now I
know John Wheeler was very worried about
these things and the worry came
particularly to a head when Martin
Schmidt Dutch astronomer well that's
American astronomy and he concluded that
there was well this was the first quasar
and he noticed that the signals from
this object well first of all they were
red shifted so that meant probably it
was receding from us is a very great
speed and secondly it was extremely
bright and thirdly it had variations in
its brightness of the order of a week or
so which suggested that it couldn't be
much bigger than the solar system and
therefore you had this huge amount of
energy coming out which is something
like you know more than the whole galaxy
and it was a real problem and the
picture which was presented was that you
had something which was down at the kind
of level that the well Oppenheimer and
schneider model would say you have a
horizon as a certain point and that this
would be where this energy would be
released at that sort of scale sorry
this point about the variability is an
important one I like to it's it's sort
of not obvious to people but it's a very
simple fine argument right I mean if
something varies rapidly then it's
probably not any bigger than it takes
light to travel across the object right
yes weak timescales that's the size of
the solar system which is small by
massive extra galactic object standards
that's right yes so it's a great puzzle
and I know wheeler was very worried
about this and he talked to me about it
and he said well if this means we've got
something down that's what's called the
Schwarzer radius the this was very early
solution
Einstein's equations called the shot
shot solution and Shmuel discovered it
soon after generals Everdeen
unfortunately he died not long after
that but it was the first solution of a
presented body he was thinking more in
terms of a star or something where there
yeah there was something inside which
was matter and the equations changed
when you get into the matter and so that
there was no singularity there but if
you imagine squashing the matter down to
this radius which is called the
Schwarzschild radius then you get into a
very curious situation which was
described by the Oppenheimer Snyder
collapse model and then so the they took
a long time right decades for people to
really appreciate what the short shield
solution was trying to tell them all
along is the tricky little general
relativity question that's right well
usually people thought there was a body
inside and so you did explore what
happened when you extended the solution
inwards and it was the first clear I
think the Alban Hyman Snyder model just
before the Second World War was a first
clear model of what could be happening
right and then the quasars like that you
mentioned I mean so there's a bright
object in the sky very far away very
small seemingly this could be a
candidate for an ultra compact object
that might be what we don't call a black
hole but so was is really accurate to
say that that experimental data nudge
theorists towards trying to understand
this absolutely true yes certainly nudge
me thinking about this you know I
thought about the Schwarzchild horizon
and so on you think much of it's a thing
that might be out there I usually won't
thought that the day if you squash the
earth down or the Sun down to that size
you well it would be pretty unrealistic
right but if the thing it's big enough
and it collapse itself inwards and I
should say that the Schwarzchild horizon
the size of it the diameter of it is
proportional to the mass of the object
so that if the object is much much
bigger than the volume which goes as the
mass cubed
is something but you wouldn't the
density wouldn't be so necessarily very
large and what is the Schwarzschild
radius for the earth I feel like it's
some it's it's tiny something like a
something like that exactly a neutron
star with the mass of the earth would be
the size of Los Angeles or something
something like that black holes is
centimeters frozen what a mass in a very
tiny area oh absolutely but you see I
know Wheeler was very worried about this
he said what happens you get this
singular idea or does it swish around
and come out again and it was it was a
big question should you trust the
Oppenheimer model Oppenheimer mother
model or is that unrealistic because of
irregularities and at that time I should
say the quasars well it was around about
1962 I think and they were round about
that time there was a an argument by two
Russians licious and kaletnik off and
they had produced a paper which seems to
say that singularities did not happen in
general circumstances right so that when
the thing collapsed if it was a general
irregular collapsing body it would swish
around it wouldn't reach these infinite
densities infinite curvatures it would
swish round and maybe come swirling out
again or something like that so that's
the picture that a lot of people had but
you were able to prove that otherwise
and what I loved about it is it in some
sense I mean this is exaggerating so I
don't know the history very well but in
some sense what you did represented a
shift in technique in general relativity
from finding exact solutions that were
simple to that making an absolutely
general statement that just relied on
the sort of intuitive powers of the
theory but made very rigorously
mathematics Allu right it's just she
either people had found models which
required a lot of ingenuity but they had
usually has some special symmetry or
something like that and these solutions
very beautiful solutions often but
whether they were realistic whether all
very special right the only other way
you could was to use high-powered
computers and work
but then in those days people didn't
have the kind of computers we have now
and it was pretty hard to get any
impressionist at what happened in the
general case so I started thinking about
this I've been thinking about other
problems a little bit like this one of
them which I never published anywhere I
was worrying about the old steady-state
model okay see this was a cosmological
model that was sort of in vogue when I
was becoming a graduate student and
becoming interested in general
relativity in a serious way and in
Cambridge where I was it was the popular
these are not bad yeah yes the universe
although it was expanding and the mass
sort of got less and less by the
expansion this the mass was replenished
by by hydrogen gas appearing
spontaneously and it was a beautiful
model in a way because as the expansion
took place the matter was replenished
and you had a universe which was sort of
stable and that remained forever in this
way as some curious properties but but
the question that I was interested in is
could you in any way make this
consistent with Einstein's general
relativity without having to introduce
negative energies and things like that
and you could see pretty well that that
couldn't be the case if it was very
symmetrical but then I started wondering
well look suppose it's irregular and
some you know quite serious way does
this still cause a problem with general
relativity and I came to the conclusion
using sort of topological types of
arguments that you couldn't save it is
it even possible to give us I know this
is a very intricate differential
topology question I mean but it's a
possible give a flavor of the argument
it's something like gravity is always
attractive right I mean that's the
principle that's certainly but it was
mainly how it bagged on light rays that
that was the the real argument you look
at how light rays behave and it's a bit
like a lens you see you have a parallel
beam of light rays
and the way that mass acts on that is to
give a it focuses like a positive lens
so convex lens wid course it's parallel
rays to focus now if you have a
stigmatic lens
suppose you imagine the lens which in
both one direction is positive in the
other direction it's negative I mean not
normally find these lenses but that's
the way gravitation behaves so if you
just go through empty space then it
focuses one way in one direction and
expands out in the other direction and
this is what leads to spaghettification
if you fall into the black hole yes it's
Russia's you wanna try and stretch you
see you know that exactly that's right
so that's what into empty space
curvature does but the thing is if you
have combinations of lenses it's quite
interesting you can do this just with
ordinary optics you have lenses and you
put them on on an optical bench and if
you had these stigmatic lenses what you
find is that if you suppose you had one
and another sitting right next to it and
a stigmatic lens which is at right
angles so I mean the they both the
planes are parallel but the direction of
rotation is at right angles then one
cancels out the other oh so it's just
like a flat piece of glass but now I
suppose you pull them apart then you
find there's a residual effect which is
a focusing effect and this is connected
with the energy in in gravitational wave
so the gravity acts like an like a nest
egg matic lens but when you have a lot
of them one after the other there's a
net effect which is focusing so there
was matter and this is the effect that
gravitational energy has is focusing so
I knew about these things about thinking
about these focusing effects and so on
and it was using this kind of argument
together with topological arguments that
you could see if you reached a point of
no return and that was a critical point
as knowing what that meant
then you would find that this focusing
property wispy would be irreversible and
you could show that that there had to be
some singular place inside the object it
was collapsing really it gets to a point
where you don't know what happens it
sort of stops space-time yeah
gives up but singular doesn't just mean
special that means the curvature is
getting infinitely big in some sense
that's the expectation although the
argument that I had didn't directly show
that it just showed that there's
something stopping this edge this base
time comes to an end and it stops right
and the normal expectation is that it
gets these focusing effects become
infinite and so things just crumple up
and you can't get any further and you
don't necessarily it doesn't immediately
follow logically that it's a black hole
right but you you had ideas about that
yes that's true
and but the argument that I had didn't
prove it's what we call a black hole it
just showed that you had the singularity
you had to make an further assumption
which is what I call cosmic censorship
which is if you if the singularities in
general how are of the kinds that you
you roughly speaking can't see them then
you do get what we think that we now
call a black hole but it did depend on
this cosmic censorship hypothesis right
which is still not completely proven is
that correct I think that's correct yes
there's a lot of evidence that it's true
I think in jail the argument is that
this has to be you look at general
situation yes that you can but you can
cook up special examples which disagree
with it but they're not realistic
so the astronomers with their data
prodded you to think about this problem
and absolutely you proved something did
your proof fraud the astronomers to take
black holes more seriously it did
eventually it was quite interesting
because you could see somehow a huge
amount of skepticism about black holes
and I used to be asked to give lectures
at these Texas symposia which happened
every I think every year first and
usually I was asked to give a talk
something about black holes and you
could see gradually people beginning to
take it seriously but there's a MOOC
that sort of went over to the other side
it sort of happened very rapidly once
once enough people got got used to the
idea and then I mean all the theoretical
side black holes became a whole area of
study and Stephen Hawking and Brandon
Carter and other people yes indeed yeah
that's right and and Hawking's
remarkable results about the fact that
they do very tiny amount of radiation
and so if you imagine in the very remote
future of the universe and these huge
black holes what you see now we see huge
ones that initially there were just the
odd double star system where you see one
star and the other one it seemed to be
going around something else that you
couldn't see but maybe there was some
plane where material was coming out of
it you couldn't see the object itself
and so see people speculated that that
was a black hole the evidence was pretty
indirect for a while but now the
evidence is well indirect in a sense
that you don't actually see directly
into the hole but you see things like in
our galaxy we have a what we call a
supermassive black hole which is about
four million times the mass of the Sun
and its really remarkable you could see
these pictures so you have to speed up a
little bit yeah
but not that much and you can see stars
going around in these sort of elliptical
orbits and and there's nothing in the
middle
going around a big heavy thing that you
can't see except it's not that big of a
small compact heavy thing you can't see
that's right it's pretty small bye-bye
yeah that's right four million solar
mass I'm not sure quite how big that is
but it's not you it's less than a
Lightyear right yeah but so when Hawking
circa 1974 argued that black holes are
not completely black if you take quantum
mechanics into account that he's radiate
how did that strike you I mean was that
a controversial I can tell you exactly
what happened he said I think I was away
from Cambridge he so I was working in
Cambridge at the time no yes it wasn't
when was this that was seventies or
early seventies I must I must have been
in Oxford but you what you and Hawking
had become close and were oh yes but the
point was I'd come back from somewhere
exactly what I can't remember I have
worked that out but Denis Sharma you see
who is a great friend of mine and I'll
cosmology from and he was Stephen
Hawking a supervisor and then this was a
great person for getting the right
people to meet each other and so on
people who might benefit from encounters
were people and he knew all the physics
that was going around so so I learned an
awful lot of physics from Dennis in
anyway I come back and Dennis told me oh
if you heard the latest Stephen Stephen
Hawking he showed that black holes
radiate you've seen I said what so I got
home owned him up piously I phoned up
Stephen and he I said what's this all
about you see and he said well it's tied
in with the ideas about thermodynamics
as a heart that makes a lot of sense so
now I I was it didn't take me long to
come to the conclusion it was probably
right but it's about to be fair to the
audience you had previously shown that
you could extract some energy from a
rotating black hole but a limited amount
and you had to do it sort of
intentionally it wouldn't be automatic
but that kind of you know pushed people
on the road to think about these
questions you could get stuff out it's
in a sense you could get energy out of
it but this was going a little further
it was it was curious because now I must
have been in Oxford because I remember
how this came about we used to have
these meetings every Friday in my office
in Oxford with my graduate students
postdocs and people interested and we if
somebody was visiting we'd have him to
give a nice little talk and Stephen was
visiting at the time and he was telling
us about he was imagining little black
holes which might be created in the Big
Bang and the idea was if they were
rotating would they lose their energy in
the rotation and he showed some
calculation about this and it was
actually not very long after that you
see I must have been visiting a country
I can't remember exactly how it was I
saw Dennis at that point but I found
Stephen up and it was really following
up on this calculation he done
previously about the rotating ones I
think that he found that they didn't
need to be rotating which rather
surprised
yes actually I think that didn't uh the
famous textbook by Kip Thorne and also
Messner and wheeler there's this picture
of an advanced civilization that has
built an energy extraction device around
the supermassive black hole the center
of their galaxy there's a lot of energy
we could in principle uh get out I'm
sorry from our dependence on foreign oil
sources if we could that was the idea
harnessed black holes well you see this
was the argument I wrote a paper in the
Italian journal there was a conference
in Italy some where I forget where now
and there were people talking about the
very massive stars and so and I was
asked to give a talk on on black holes
which I did but I come to this
conclusion that you could extract energy
and I imagined that you could do this by
having particles which would split up
into two and so on but when it came to
the talk I guess in which way around was
I think I did get it that way around but
I thought about also about the
civilizations rotating around the whole
and extracting energy yeah and there's a
simple argument you can see they could
do this from quite general principles
they just lower you know fill buckets
full of right rubbish no the whole tip
the rubbish in and they would extract
more energy than the mass of the rubbish
and when Hawking did explain the black
holes give off radiation this all came
as part of this as you mentioned
thermodynamics yes it's for hackage then
it's like holes have entropy yes and
there was this sort of analogy between
what black holes do in the laws of
thermodynamics and this really said it's
not analogy it's true rifles have
entropy but it was curious because you
see the entropy of the black although it
was really bekenstein has had had a
fairly rough argument but I was quite
happy with that because it seemed to be
very consistent that the area of the
black hole should should have an entropy
and the deccan signs are pretty
convincing to me but Stephen then had a
much more exact argument and which was
more impressive mathematically but this
came after a lot of discussions between
Stephen and Brandon Carter and
and who is the other one I know the
paper you're talking about is the laws
of life whole mechanics but I'll tell
the audience afterwards and then maybe I
think yeah but this they were exploring
the analogy between thermodynamics and
and black holes but Stephen definitely
just thought it was an analogy I might
be talking to him about this and I was
sort of thinking it was real you see but
you see in a way he'd been looking more
deeply into it than I had because he
realized if it was really thermodynamic
then the black holes had to have a
temperature yeah just swallow thing is
there's no way it can have a temperature
you see right but then he found that
they did I mean I think that he in a
brief history of time he mentioned that
he was literally annoyed at bekenstein
for suggesting the energy was real and
that motivated him to do this that's
interesting I hadn't quite realized it
was that argument that that's right
did that help get you interested in
entropy because it was just a few years
after that that you started talking
about the entropy of the early universe
it must have done I'd have to try and
put it together but to be able to assign
a value to this entropy that that was
crucial for that I see I can't quite
remember the order of my thinking here
but but a big certainly something which
I played around with a lot was thinking
about well I thought about it in the
steady state model you see you know an
ESU entry issue of entropy balance
trouble to me you see but there you see
you had this creation of the hydrogen
which which the fact that it was could
condense you see in form objects could
be a source of the entropy and so source
of low entropy I should say a reservoir
of low entropy so that's how it's sort
of squared itself in my mind with the
second law issue I'm been worrying about
it then already but when that had to be
given up a mum was looking at models
width which expanded and didn't have
creation of matter at some point I was
worrying about this question but didn't
really have substance to it until
Hawking entropy because
hoping entropy value for black holes and
how huge it was yes so just I need to be
very fair to all the audience listeners
entropy they've heard the word before
but it's roughly speaking a measure of
how random disorganized a certain system
is John and in some sense intuitively
you might have thought that a black hole
has zero entropy it's not a lot of
different ways a black hole can be right
it's not like a cup of coffee with a lot
of arrangements of the atoms inside but
Hawking in bekenstein show that is
actually a huge number and that inspired
you in some sense to start writing about
the second law of thermodynamics says
that entropy tends to increase in closed
systems and therefore it's not
surprising that entropy used to be lower
in the past but cosmologists have a long
history of being confused about this
issue yes yeah and I think that let's
just be honest that this is the the most
profound that has been quite a profound
effect that you have had on my career
because it was your papers emphasizing
this problem of why the early diverse
had such a low entropy which I thought
were completely convincing and puzzled
by why my fellow cosmologists don't take
this seriously so why don't you explain
how you think it maybe it was a few one
of the few people really latched on to
it immediately but it's I was just as
possible my people didn't take it
seriously but the basic argument is this
as you said I mean the entropy or the
randomness if you like increases with
time and that's the second law another
way of saying exactly the same thing is
you go back in time it decreases so as
you go back and back and back in time
you should find the entropy very small
now what's the earliest evidence we
directly see of the universe's state
that's the Cosmic Microwave Background
so this is radiation coming from all
directions electromagnetic radiation and
this radiation has a lot of entropy in
it but the main point that I'm going to
sort of concentrate on here is if you
look at the the the curve which
represents the intensity for different
frequencies you have this thing the
curve goes up and then comes down again
and it has its what's called the Planck
curve the amount of light at different
wavelength that's right so that so
there's a certain
temperature where it's maximum and then
in the radiation at higher frequencies
it goes goes down and this Planck curve
is observed the COBE satellite when it
went up you'll have to tell me the dates
that don't remember 1991-92 okay the
COBE satellite measured this curve of
this intensity for different frequencies
of this radiation to find an extremely
good fit almost perfect fit to the to
the planck spectrum what's the Planck
spectrum tell us it tells us what we're
looking at its maximum entropy I mean
that's the whole point of it it's what
they call the blackbody radiation which
meant maximum entropy so here this is
what I call the mammoth in the room you
go back and back in time where the
entropy supposed to be going down and
down and down till it reaches a maximum
which is sort of the wrong way around
and and I don't know why people didn't
worry about that more but the point is
the answer I think partly because it's a
muddled up with the expansion of the
universe that people think oh well the
universe is expanding and so maybe
there's not much room for entropy down
there or something like that I think
it's partly that and partly that when
we're taught thermodynamics gravity is
not a part of it yes I mean there were
people I like Tolman one of the early
mathematical physicists who studied
cosmology and he understood pretty well
about the entropy issue so people
certainly did understand it the right
people at that time but anyway yeah
you've got this huge amount of entropy
in the radiation which is a lot actually
and then why is the second law home when
it starts off at the top I'm it's got
nowhere to go if you're I think and you
can have to convince yourself that the
expanding universe doesn't help which is
a point Tom and did understand but the
other issue you see what this radiation
coming from all directions and which it
has this thermal character but the other
point about this is also very uniform so
it's almost completely uniform over the
whole sky if you take account of the
Earth's motion through the radiation it
is uniform over the sky too
about one part in 100,000 so it's really
pretty uniform now you see what does
that indicate you say well okay suppose
you have a gas in the box then the
temperature would be pretty uniform if
it's it's a maximum entropy state you
just leave it in the box and the
temperature apart from gravity and all
that stuff it would be uniform
temperature so that also finds
represents high entropy so where is it
low
well it's low if you think of not a gas
in the box
but suppose you think of a huge box of
galactic scale and it's got stars
running around in it now those stars
will tend to clump because of their
gravitational attraction and eventually
become black holes and as they do this
the entropy goes shooting up
particularly with the black holes
because as we know from bacon stylin
hawking the entropy is absolutely
enormous so that represents an increase
in entropy so they you have these two
things about the early universe one is
the Planck spectrum which tells you the
that the the matter and radiation see
the Planck spectrum was telling you that
the early stage of the universe photons
and matter were kind of maximal and
randomized as much as they could be and
so that radiation comes to us and you
see this plank spectrum but the other
feature about it is that it's uniform
and that as far as gravity is concerned
is very low entropy because as things
start to clump and a good example of
this is our son our son used to be a
long time think how a distribution of
gas all over the place and it went
through various stages but it could
clump together and produce this hot body
it would be hot even if there were no
fermi nuclear reactions at all so it
gets that heat which is when compared
the darkness of this background sky is a
very low entropy situation you can get
energy out of it by simply we do we do
absolutely that's why we're here the
plants do by photosynthesis and we live
off plants and animals of eat plants and
so on and so that's where it all comes
from so it comes from the fact that the
sun's a hot spot in a cold background
sky and this is why we are interested in
the second law of thermodynamics because
it's low and it's creeping up is what we
get our structure from and all that
stuff so ultimately the Cosmic Microwave
Background it looks like it's maximum
entropy but that's only because you
forgot could have been all these
lumpiness --is we clearly they tend to
be much lower like I think it's true the
entropy of the black hole at the center
of our galaxy is larger than the entire
entropy of the Cosmic Microwave
Background that could well be yes and if
you look at it thinking all the stars
with all the galaxies things around it's
absolutely enormous like the entropy in
the black holes is absolutely stupendous
by comparison
anything else so this is very good news
for the second law of thermodynamics it
explains that the early universe had a
low entropy actually not a maximum
entropy that's right it's bad news for
cosmology because we're stuck with this
question of why the early universe is
like that exactly a lot of cosmologists
like the theory of inflation proposed by
Alan Guth around 1980 and you were one
of the first gadfly's they're saying
that inflation is a bit of a cheat I
think yes what do you see I thought this
is a crazy idea it won't last a week how
wrong I was no it's completely wrong it
just seems to me such an artificial
theory you have to invent a special
field well use in the old days they call
it a Higgs field because I hope that the
Higgs field would be the same as that
but that didn't work I mean we should
explain that the basic idea is that the
universe underwent is very very early
times yes a period of super fast
accelerated expansion which I think it I
think you would agree it's true that if
that happened and if the energy driving
that expansion turned into matter and
radiation it would give you a universe
looking like our universe but it doesn't
help explain the internal condition yes
it doesn't because you've got to have a
pretty uniform already otherwise it
doesn't even work right so it's you you
can have quite general arguments to show
that it can't really be the
nation of the low just not just a low
entropy in the early unis this
particular form that it's low namely in
gravitational degrees of freedom right
and it just struck me strange why cause
largest you know you can see a list of
what is it what are the problems of
cosmology and you look down the list and
say where is this yeah totally on your
side there but so so both of us are you
know in the small band of people who've
been trying to invent models of the
universe which naturally explain this
early entropy but that's where we
diverge so I I think they didn't I think
that inflation I would honestly give it
a 50% chance I'd seen being a part of
the final answer that's a lot more than
I'm giving it exactly but a lot lower
than all my friends give it right that's
professional geologist so and you've
been working very recently on a new
model of the universe on its sumer
largest scales that's right well
recently isn't even all that recently
sits I forget nicely over 10 years
anyway ok but nobody paid well you see
it took me a long time to I used to
lecture about let me explain the model
firstly the argument is that you think
of the two ends of the universe we have
this future which seems to be dominated
by this exponential expansion so this is
observations of supernova stars and
other things together which persuaded
cosmologists enough to give the two
groups the Nobel Prize which was very
deserved to see that the universe is
having this what's called an exponential
expansion it's it's a sort of
self-similar the rate of expansion is is
proportional to the size and so on so
it's it's something which seems to be
taking place now those of us who were
brought up on cosmology and written to
cosmology books would have seen that
these kinds of models for that
exponential expansion are perfectly well
described in the books these are models
in which there is a thing called the
cosmological constant which is positive
and it's usually referred to as a lambda
capital lambda it's like a V upside down
right basically the energy of empty
space well you can think of it as people
call it dark energy yes yes I I'm not
sure I'm happy without him but but never
mind us that's it's certainly well
explained by this by this Einstein
cosmological constant Einstein
introduced this term in 1919 seventeen
for what was the wrong reason he wanted
a model which was static he hoped if the
universe was static I think it's a sort
of appealing idea the steady-state model
is have gained the same sort of appeal
philosophically appealing in some way be
fair I think it was also the
observations at the time the universe
look static to astronomers in 1917 I
think I guess hopple hadn't quite right
it was like aliens it was but it was
after I can't remember it was after the
best Oh Slifer wasn't it because bestest
Slifer had already seen the expansion
maybe it wasn't such a convincing
argument what you saw that they were
distant uh you saw that there were
objects that were moving away from us
yes I guess you know if they were far
away I guess that's true it probably
wasn't terribly persuasive but there was
some indication yet not enough to to
rule out a model like Einstein the one
he produced then but for that model he
needed this term and it's the only thing
you can really do to Einstein's
equations without wrecking them in my
view you just add this term and you
didn't like to do this at first but then
I guess he thought well let's put it in
and didn't he get a static model which
we refer to as the Einstein cosmology
but then not long after that Hubble
showed pretty convincingly that there
was this expansion in proportion to the
distance so the whole universe seemed to
be taking part in this expansion and so
I started I guess they're kicking
himself for not having stuck to his
original equations which seemed to
indicate he would have predicted it you
could have become famous yeah
you could hang famous yes well he
considered this to be his greatest
blunder and I think that's true it's on
record I think
gamm office recorded Einstein having
said this so okay this is but it's all
in the cosmology books despite right
Einstein sort of retracting it and yeah
people studying I I studied it I didn't
look to see what the Infinity looked
like in this model and so on so I was
familiar with it although I I it was bit
slow on the uptake to taking it
seriously I think it was Jerry
Ostreicher who told me I said well you
know maybe this distant supernovae look
red because of dusts and so on which
people thought maybe was the case and he
said no no there all sorts of other
things it's got you yeah it's not just
that you have to take it seriously so I
thought okay how take it seriously and
it wasn't I don't know how long after
that conversation that I began to think
about the remote future now you see the
remote remote future and I mean the very
real future we have the universe expands
and expands and expands and it gets more
and more rarefied and nothing much
happens you get sort of dead stars and
it gets pretty boring and the most
exciting things are around these black
holes but they're pretty boring to you
sit around waiting it to for it to
evaporate according to Hawking's
evaporation and for the big ones it
takes about a googol year something like
that so you're thinking about ten to the
hundred years one with 100 zeros that
number yes yes and that's an awful long
time so I regard that it's a pretty
boring area we'll wait for that but then
you see after it's gone off pop by by
Hawking evaporation now that's the very
boy yes right I mean I couldn't think of
anything more boring than that and I
admit this is an emotional argument but
it just seemed to me for our universe
that's it you see it's forever and ever
just in eternal tedium you see well it
is weird and I think that cosmologists
under emphasize how weird it is we
always talk about the last fourteen
billion years of the history of the
universe because that's the past that's
what we'd observed and we we say it's a
long time and so forth
our best current models say we have
infinity years just toward the future
rather big imbalance and intent and
interminable in Tamil oh yeah boredom
yes well you see then I began to think
well who's gonna be around to be bored
by this I thought well pretty well
photons and it's damn hard to boil
photon that's actually I don't expect it
to have edge actual experiences so
boring is perhaps not an appropriate
term again to be fair I did interviewed
David Chalmers on the podcast and he
thinks that photons can have actually
just a little bit baby think about the
photons feelings here let's take those
in okay well that helps me because they
still don't get bored they don't get
bored because if you take relativity now
this is children a old fashioned special
relativity without the curved space-time
and all that doesn't matter curved or
not the photon the Kazakh travel from
the speed of light the time is just
stretched out and it's nothing so right
from anything from its creation in some
particle decay or something this photon
goes out to infinity and it extent
experiences zero time so it's not bought
in the sense I forget about whether it
actually has feelings and it doesn't
experience the passage of time now this
is a sort of thing I used to play around
but if I'm thinking about gravitational
radiation and how you put boundaries on
space times and so on and it was a
useful way to think that this boundary
is something you could imagine going
through and if you were a massless thing
when you hit that bound you say well
will the hell am I you see there's got
to be something on the other side you
might think I mean it's only a way of
thinking I didn't think can give it this
seriously that way so okay let's think
just to get just correct in people's
minds this is a boundary that we're
talking about that is literally
infinitely far away but you're saying
the photon experience is zero time so it
gets there that's exactly right
but I think it's very useful if you have
seen these pictures by the Dutch artist
MC Escher there's a very famous one with
angels and devils
they in the middle you can see the
ancient angels on there and Devils
interlocking and then you go out there's
a circular boundary and they get seemed
to get smaller and smaller and smaller
and they crowd in on that boundary now
you this is a representation of a kind
of geometry which is called a hyperbolic
geometry and if you think of those
angels is really all being the same size
as each other the Devils all the same
size then although it looks to us as
though they get smaller and smaller to
them they're all the same size and did
you have something to do with inspiring
that sure no that was that was my
relation to I sure was something it's
not that little different but that was
coxeter it was the same the same meeting
yes this was in the International
Congress of mathematicians and whenever
it was early 57 okay and yeah the
mathematician coxeter who wrote to a
show and said well you might find this
interesting
to say so so no that was a
representation it's in the spirit of
what you did for space-time in general
relativity so you can express infinitely
far away things in a finite piece of
paper exactly that's what it is and the
thing about this Asha picture is its
what's called conformal so that means
that small shapes are accurately just
the squash down you look at the eye of
the devil if you like it's called a
certain shape and no matter how close to
the edge you get in a room it retains
that shape is smaller so it's squashed
in one direction and equally well in all
other directions so it's what's called a
conformal
representation so it's a conformal
picture of an infinite universe but
where you see infinity as a finite in a
finite place now you can use the same
trick in cosmology but then you are
thinking of space-time or not space and
what conformal means is that you
preserve the speed of light if you like
the things called the light cones which
tell you like how the speed of light
goes I like goes and so they're
squashing down of infinity if you are
light you don't notice the difference in
fact it's a more general thing it's if
you don't have any mass you
notice the difference if you move at the
speed of light at the speed of light and
it's also a fact not thinking particles
with the fields and the electromagnetic
field which slightest thee is a feature
electromagnetic field this is Maxwell's
famous equations and these equations of
Maxwell again are insensitive to the
scale so you can squash it and stretch
as long as you do it equally in both
directions in in space-time that means
you squash the time in the space equally
then that kind of transformation is not
noticed by light or not noticed by the
Maxwell equations right and that's true
also of the yang-mills equations of
particle physics and nuclear physics so
now the nuclear force is the strong oh
except for mass so you've got to be
careful you better get rid of things
which which may disturb the conform but
but the equations themselves as
classical equations are completely
insensitive to the scale so anything
which doesn't have mass that boundary
which we've just drawn is just like
anywhere else
now that's infinity you see well it's
not quite because we have to worry about
the black holes but the black holes
eventually decay we're already so we got
rid of that to see but the other end you
say well what's the excuse for
stretching out the big bang to make it
look similar
now the excuse there is not an excuse
because most big bangs don't work wait
sorry I think that we maybe skipped a
step around just close attention but you
you're you're you've been explaining the
future and it has a certain nice
remarkable mathematical properties yeah
and your move is to relate it to the
past right to say like actually the very
past of the universe kind of look
similar maybe we can make some money off
ethically that's right now you you can
use a similar trick but the opposite way
around so in the future you have to
squash it down so you like the Escher
picture in the past I've tried to find a
national picture which did it for the
this is quiet there's so much almost do
it but if you go into the past you can
stretch it out now all the standard
cosmology is the ones that what Freeman
the matron robertson-walker the the
cosmologists the the models that most
cosmologists play with do have the
property that you can stretch out the
Big Bang in those models to make it nice
and smooth but almost all models if you
think of what possible things that can
be in Einstein's equations they're a
great mess at the beginning and they
don't have a nice smooth Big Bang but
those ones which do have a nice smooth
Big Bang are ones that you can stretch
out and make it a nice conformal
boundary and those are the ones which
you could say that the gravitation
degrees of freedom are killed off right
at the beginning so you have a nice
picture with the entropy low in gravity
but not low in anything else and so
that's being able to do that trick is
seems consistent with what we seem to
see of the universe and my former
student and colleague Paul Todd used
this as a criterion for the kinds of big
bangs that one might be interested in
but that they you can stretch them out
in this conformal way now you see the
what's the argument here you want to say
in the future it's because you're toast
messes things around in the past well
you see the argument is sort of similar
but not quite the same there you have
very very large temperatures get hotter
and hotter the closer you get into the
Big Bang that means more and more and
more energetic the particles are and
when they get very energetic in the
sense of their emotions kinetic energy
and that completely swamps the masses
they're effectively mass yeah so they're
effectively massless so really we're on
the Big Bang everything is pretty well
massless so it's sort of reasonable
physically to do these tricks at both
ends so what you're suggesting what
you've called it is a conformal cyclic
cosmology yeah you think our universe
has an infinite number presumably of
cycles my Big Bang to stuff like us to
the future and then repeats yes but the
other idea is that our Big Bang was the
conformal infinity of a previous Eon I
caused an eon I like not to call our
universe because
we're all entangle with each other and
it's a part of one big thing so Ariane a
yo and I like to think of it as began
with a big bang and ends in a sense with
the squashed off infinity but if you
apply the stretching at the beginning
and the squashing in the future you get
a thing which looks a bit like a
cylinder and you can imagine that
joining on to another tube which was the
previous Eon so it's from most remote
future conformally smoothly fits onto
our Big Bang and one of the exciting
aspects is it might be observational II
testable absolutely well there are some
new features on this at first sight I
used to give lectures about this and
said this is this is fun and I can go on
talking about this and nobody will ever
prove me wrong we've seen with its right
a lot but then I started having an idea
maybe one could see a test and so the
first thing I thought of was what about
black hole collisions
you see our galaxy has a supermassive
black hole in its center size for four
million times the mass of Sun I think
the Andromeda galaxy is one about twenty
times bigger or something like that and
we are on a collision course with it
it's not very near in the future but you
have there we're thinking bigger yes but
eventually these black holes will
galaxies collide and black holes will
feel each other out it'll take a while
finally spiral into each other and there
will be one working explosion which will
carry away a significant proportion of
the rest mass of the combined black
holes and that would be gravitational
radiation primarily likely like our
detection of the black holes and that we
seen and very proud of and now it's this
is a far far bigger explosion right we
might be lucky to see such a thing in
the very distant future I've just well
it's just in the future I don't know
anyway this explosion would carry out to
the crossover between one Yeun and the
next
and it's you have to look at the
equation it's not you see need equations
to do the gluing job from one to the
next and okay you can produce equations
which have nice behavior and they indeed
kill off the gravitational degrees of
freedom but they don't kill it off and
the degrees of freedom survive but not
as gravitational waves they come through
as disturbances in the newly created
dark matter so you have to have to make
the equations work you have to have we
talked about dark energy but this is
dark matter and that seems to be some
real substance out there but in this
theory it's got to be there it's got to
be where the degrees of freedom of a
gravitational waves get picked up and
translated into this form on the other
side and these would produce signals
that could be seen they would look like
circular features maybe concentric ones
because in a cluster of galaxies you
know there'd be a lot of battles between
black holes swallowing each other up and
then end up with one big whacking one in
the middle of a cluster and that's the
one but there are claims and arguments
about whether we see these rings I think
the most persuasive argument was from my
polish colleagues they first looking at
the W Maps satellite and then the latest
satellite is this Planck satellite which
did some very very precise measurements
of cosmic microwave background radiation
and they claim to see signals of this
nature with a confidence level this is
looking at the Planck data with a
confidence level of 99.4% nevertheless
people don't pay attention I mean have
they argued against it or they just it's
very strange because the I mean it had a
lot of trouble with referees who said
look you've got to do this and then we
don't don't believe you you've got to do
this test that test they did them all
they big polls were absolutely this is
Christoph Meisner and perform a rough
ski and there was Daniel man who it was
a Korean who did the analysis in that
case and they in a Planck data come on
they they came to this conclusion 99.4%
confidence using all the tests but the
editor said more or less well I'm afraid
we're going to have to accept your paper
you see despite all the complaints
people had but what you should say in
the initial part of the paper this might
be a chance effect it's always possible
yeah it's good Joseph but this is what
the good news is you know it's in the
data the data hopefully will improve
you've made a prediction
we also gorilla was more exciting it's
what's happened more recently okay you
see this is the same more or less the
same team the Polish team with Daniel
man and they were doing it as a slightly
more sophisticated analysis which came
from a discussion that had was Christoph
- well maybe you could refine the
signals and see what the shapes of them
are and so on and they then found a
particularly strong signal for some very
small ring-like structures and this
puzzling to me at first because it
should be a source of evidence for the
bigger ones but it didn't seem nearly so
impressive as a small ones but then it
occurred to me that I had thought about
this before but I've not really dared
think about it seriously which is the
question of what happens to these
supermassive black holes
see any cluster will end up with a big
whopping great black hole in its center
this will gradually gradually decay over
something like a 10 to 100 years Google
yes I mean sorry in fact any cluster
turns into a whopping big block pretty
well yes I think pretty well all the
matter gets swallowed I don't know
exactly what proportion it is but you
would expect I would guess pretty well
most most pretty well all the matter
gets swallowed up so you've got this
black hole sitting there and it sits
there and eventually it decays away by
Hawking evaporation now you see holding
evaporation is a very cold most of it
and you know could pretty well ignore it
normally long wavelength and yeah but as
a total it carries away the entire mass
of that supermassive black hole and
where does that mass go when you think
go think about the Escher picture again
you see you have an event which is
taking place right up near the edge of
that boundary and that means all the
radiation which comes out is
concentrated right at one little point
so you would have according to this skit
theory what I refer to as a Hawking
point you see the Hawking evaporations
and these Hawking points would be a
release of an enormous amount of energy
right at that point and then it was
spread out through about 380,000 years
which is the time between the Big Bang
and the last scattering surface where
you see the microwave background and the
amount it spreads out is - well four
degrees which is about eight times the
diameter of the moon so it looks quite a
sizable thing but pretty small on the
basis of looking at the whole sky so
you'd imagine spots of that size we
wouldn't see them quite that size
because our past light cone only cuts
through a bit of it so there so they
look at a technical point but they're
comparable that size they may be say 5
times the diamond or something like that
but this is just the scale in which the
latest analysis you seem to see an
effect and this would be regions where I
mean look at rings and you imagine this
ring surrounding the Hawking point and
in the middle it's hot and then it cools
down as you get towards the edge of the
ring as the energy gets dispersed
through this this period of time from
the Big Bang to the 100 380,000 years
and that spread you can see is
concentrated in the middle and spreads
out and it's completely consistent with
that and now the latest thing which is
just about I think now on on the archive
the latest version of this article is we
given a
confidence level from the looking at
simulations and things of 99.98%
confidence now this is just clearly out
there and the data anybody else can look
they can and if they see something else
when we will have to see why why we or
see a different thing but the evidence
seems to be out there and it has this
confidence level he's completely clearly
calculated of ninety nine point ninety
eight percent now one of the real
problems for inflation of this you see
is that the point you would be seeing
not the Big Bang inflation would be
what's called the the graceful exit
moment so inflation in the inflation if
modeling okay started very close to the
big guy and then this huge expansion
took place and most things which happen
in that region of this huge inflationary
expansion would be spread out to an
enormous size so only at the very end
would you get something which is
restricted to this four degrees across
the sky and we don't see the signal
bigger than that that's the size of it
so if people come around and say yes
they see the same signal we do and they
I don't see why they can't do that then
they would say well how is this an
inflationary effect if it's due to
inflation it would be have something
which just happened at the last minute
just just as inflation turned off at
this point where they have a lot of
trouble with anyway call it graceful
exit that was one of the reasons I had
trouble believing in it how you turn the
blasted thing off uniformly over the
whole universe which seems a great
problem and more of a problem now
because it's not just uniform you've got
other little points with us a huge
amount of energy spewing out and I'm
waiting to see what the inflation or the
explanation will be for these things but
the good news is they're you know we're
talking about data now we're talking
about observations other people can
repeat the you know absent we'll see
what comes out of that good and you've
written a book about the conformal like
I did I wrote a book yes it was I talked
a little about the black hole collisions
not but nobody seen them at that point I
since I didn't make any particular point
of
observation just that it potentially was
possible I do I do want to you know plug
the books this is part of that part of
appearing on after your reward for
appearing on the podcast
Thank You cycles of time it's like was
the time excellent good available
wherever your books are available um but
it's not the only book you've written
you've been very happy to go and write
books about all sorts of topics I think
that people are gonna want to hear about
quantum mechanics oh yeah if that's okay
I think we've talked about quantum
mechanics on the podcast before
certainly we will going forward there's
the measurement problem and the quantum
mechanics has this weird feature that
there seems to be a thing that we need
to include in the description that is
what happens when you look at something
unlike any other theory ever in physics
this and so like many people you've been
dissatisfied by the standard approaches
to this problem so how do you how do you
like to think about it well I see I take
the view that quantum mechanics is not
finished I mean I I don't like to quote
Authority Abel acts I do because they're
right right I mean Einstein was always
but you know he was doubtful about the
theory being a complete description of
what goes on and Schrodinger you know
put port with the equation which which
quantum theory is supposed to satisfy
well he was troubled with it you can see
because he put forward this ridiculous
situation of the cat which is a
superposition of life that as an example
of the absurdity of following his own
equation okay so he's not saying look
this is what happens he's saying this is
an absurd thing we don't understand
what's going on and that doesn't mean
that they're right but if those people
were worried then we have a license to
be worried a little bit that's right
well Dirac also you have to find the
right quote there because he didn't
express himself very much but you from
the right place he was also just a
skeptical I didn't know they knew what
I'm saying that's that's yeah that's
less well known but T know he regarded
quantum mechanics as a provisional
theory it works very well but we need
something better I'm not sure how
explicit he was about what it is that's
worrying him and maybe it was
divergences as well but I think it was
probably the measurement issue there's a
wonderful book by Adam Becker
called what is real that just came out
which makes the case that we we tell
ourselves this false story about
Einstein and Bohr where Einstein just
couldn't keep by and that Bohr got it
right but in fact Einstein
you know his arguments were better but
he lost the PR battle back in the day
seem to be that yes well it's quite
curious because my view he was thinking
on the right lines because he was
bringing in gravitational effects and
bought at this particular case and saw a
way of resolving the issue in favor of
the conventional view but that was
because they never really considered the
effect of gravity on things it was the
effect in gravity and it's when you
think of the effect of gravity that's
where things change at least that's my
view and you can make I believe a good
argument that there is a basic
contradiction between the basic
principles of both theories now when I
say the basic principles in gr are
general relativity this is the principle
of equivalence that is to say a
gravitational field is like an
acceleration so if you fall freely in a
uniform field the gravitational field is
gone
as far as the physics is concerned and
the principle in quantum mechanics which
I'm concerned with here is the principle
of superposition which says if you have
a an object which can be in one place
and if it can be in another place then
they're perfectly good states where it's
in both places at once and you can see
this with neutrons and things that's the
way behave things behave but when it
comes to cricket balls or baseballs
that's not what you see and the question
is why what's the difference and I was
it's curious because I went to lectures
when I was in Cambridge doing I was just
working on pure mathematics but I went
to lectures on various things that
interested me like consume ology in
generality by Blondie of course some
mathematical logic by man and Christine
about girls theorem and Turing machines
and things and then there was a lecture
by Dirac and I think it was his his
first lecture where he talked about the
superposition principle and he had a
piece of chalk and he I think he broke
it into as an image of where it could be
in two places at once and he
talked about it and my mind wandered for
a bit my don't know what I was thinking
about and when it came back to the
subject he'd moved on and I remember him
saying something about energy it wasn't
quite sure what I think it's just as
well I didn't hear his explanation
because it might have calmed me down but
instead I worried about this or ever
since ever since so how is it that big
massive bodies don't you know two places
at once but then you see if you look at
the principle of I have any example
about this you think of an experiment
done on the tabletop which involves the
Earth's gravitational field and you can
treat the two different ways either the
sort of Newtonian way which is the
standard quantum mechanics procedure
putting what's called a term in the
Hamiltonian don't worry about what that
means but it's what they do and the ad
stallion way which please no no you
pretend that you take a freely falling
frame and there isn't a gravitational
field and then you compare the answers
you have a thing called the wavefunction
in each case and the two calculations
are almost the same if you look at them
carefully whether they differ by what's
called the phase factor which usually
don't care about and so if you've stuck
to one well if you look at them
carefully you see that this thing called
a phase factor actually has a little
awkward thing with the time cubed in it
which tells you that actually what's
called the the vacuum see when you do
quantum field theory you have to there's
a thing you have to do it you have to
settle on what the vacuum is and then I
think it was an interesting place in
quantum field it yes exactly and and
what you find is that the vacuum is
different in these two approaches now
this might not matter because you said
stick to one unified but now I think of
a different situation where you've got
an experiment which not the Earth's
field you can forget about that because
it sort of canceled that but the main
point is that the Einsteinian point of
view when you have this superposition if
you look at what a little bug would feel
here they superpose lump it's got one
vacuum for one position and the other
vacuum from the other and you you're
stuck because in standard quantum
mechanics you
form these super positions when it's
different back here so what I do is to
say okay well let's go through as best
we can and see if there's a kind of
error that you could attribute yeah it's
not quite right but how far off either
and so sorry just to conceptualize this
it's because the gravitational field of
the thing is different that you can't
sort of have a consistent quantum
description of both fields at once
yes it's Renison that the lump is in two
places here and here then its
gravitational field if you take the
Einstein point of view of three four
which gets rid of the gravity and then
you have a different vacuum so for each
of these two locations you have a
different quantum field theory and that
doesn't make any sense you can't thank
you go go ahead with your standard
procedures if you've got two different
fun a few theories for the to lump
positions right so you're in trouble so
actually I mean technically you're in
trouble
so what I try to do is say well how do
you estimate the error or the
uncertainty or whatever it is and you do
a little calculation and you come to a
measure of what this trouble is how big
is it and it's like an uncertainty in
the energy of the system and then I say
well it's a bit like an unstable
particle and what you find is that for
an unstable nucleus a there is an energy
uncertainty which is inversely related
to its lifetime and this is standard
physics and this inverse relationship is
part of the Heisenberg uncertainty
relationship with the time you have time
energy uncertainty okay you might it's
sort of using it the other way around so
people say if you would know the
lifetime of the system what is the
uncertainty in the in the energy now I'm
saying that you have an uncertainty in
the energy what's the lifetime what do I
mean my lifetime yeah the lifetime yes
is that it decays into one location or
the other now that's your that's my
proposal I should say that there is a
Hungarian physical do she who had a very
similar model before me he didn't have
this particular motivation so it was
more here so here's a suggestion that
you
how a super post state might become one
or the other by itself spontaneously
nobody is the point is that it's not
something coming and looking at it you
see nothing to do with observer that's
right nothing it was observers or if any
if it's anything it's observing itself
or something but do you think of this as
a modification of conventional quantum
mechanics or a completion of it it's
it's not there in the textbooks right
it's not in the textbooks I think it's a
modification yeah okay it's going to
need a theory alright I don't have a
theory it's going to need a revolution
in UCI I think if there's something like
this Newton's gravitational theory
survived a long time beautifully and
well people started to see things like
the motion of mercury which didn't quite
agree with the theory and maybe there
was a little extra planning called
Vulcan or maybe there's some other
explanation or so on and then Einstein
explained it by not modifying Newton's
theory by putting another term in it or
something by looking at it completely
differently right so I'm a partisan of
ever-ready in quantum mechanics of many
worlds I've wondered a little bit
although I haven't sat down and gone
through the equations but in Everett we
talk about wave functions branching
because of decoherence because a system
interacts with an environment and one
way you know there's a big challenge in
quantum computing to prevent systems
from acting reacting with the
environment so that you can maintain
quantum coherence yeah but one thing you
can never escape is gravity right so
everything has a gravitational field if
you're in a superposition of two
different places where your
gravitational field would be different
yeah I can at least imagine that there
are virtual gravitons that are you know
that in the particle physics language
that in the classical language we would
say slightly different gravitational
fields that could interact with the
world and cause decoherence and maybe
just because gravity is mediated by
massless particles there's a sort of an
inevitable branching of the wavefunction
that leads to collapse in a way that is
at least morally similar to what you're
talking about I think you if you do take
an average interview you've got to have
something else like this to tell you
what a world is
in a sense because you want to be able
to say it's this world or that world and
then you have no in the world is it some
because it's some quantum mechanical
mess of everything entangled with
everything else or is it sort of singled
out by having a well-defined geometric
space-time structure in other words the
world to find gravitational field now I
very much agree I think that people who
do foundations of quantum mechanics
generally don't think too much about
general relativity in space-time and or
if they are experts in if they don't
think of the two problems are related
but I do think that that's something
people should take part yes well I think
you see there's a lot of talk about
quantum gravity you see people say well
we want to bring the two subjects
together these two great 20th century
revolutions that's fine but they usually
concentrate on how quantum mechanics
might affect space-time structure or
gravity and this is where you're looking
at things that were tiny scale of 10 to
the minus 33 centimeters and 10 to the
minus 43 seconds and things like that
which are way off the range of
experimental tests so you might have to
build an accelerator the size of the
solar system or something like that in
order to get the energies needed to to
explore this kind of level but this is
much more optimistic this is the effect
of gravity on quantum mechanics not of
quantum mechanics on gravity and this or
you could call it gravity as quantum
mechanics you see and here it's not bad
at all you're just looking at
experiments which you're on the verge of
being done or being tried even now and
other experiments coming up which could
well give maybe direct evidence of this
one of the latest ideas is using
bose-einstein condensates these are very
very quantum mechanical States very very
cold almost absolute zero and you can
play around with them in interesting
ways and you could put them into
positions of two places at once
and maybe see what happens it's it's
it's sort of it's experimentally just
about the level that can be done and
you've gone further than that you've
suggested it happens in our brains
yeah yes well that's the audience we
sure he should mention that in part
you've done this in collaboration with
Stuart Hameroff who's in the room right
now you can say hi Stuart yeah he's
there so which came first your
consciousness thoughts as it were or
your quantum mechanics thoughts or when
did they get to get together well you
see the corner can't so it came first
but not that long before because I
mentioned these lecture courses I went
to and the Dirac issue about where there
is seems to be a gap in our present
understanding quite he didn't put it
like that but that was what I felt but
then I also went to this course on
mathematical logic and I had been struck
by I'd had long conversations as an
undergraduate with Ian Percival who we
used to discuss these things a lot and
this issue of mathematical or we had you
know played around with logical systems
and formal logic and so on and then I
Begley heard about girdle's theorem
which seems to tell us that there are
things in mathematics you couldn't prove
and I didn't like that idea so I went to
the lecture course which was very
revealing first of all I learned about I
about some Turing machines what what
modern computers are based on if you
like so I knew what the notion of
computation was basically quantity Rima
Sheen can do which is very beautiful
mathematical idea and that there are
certain things that are outside
computation so it's aware of this this
things you know things that you can
computers and things which are outside
computation or beyond universal
computation and then I learned about the
girdle theorem and it was not that you
things you can't see a true or false or
something sure that if you have any
logical system let's say something you
the steps you could put them on a
computer so let's say your computational
computational checkable so you have a
line of argument which is meant to be a
proof of some mathematical statement it
could be like that
there must last theorem and Andrew Wiles
famously proved or it could be the
Goldbach conjecture which nobody has
proved it if it's true well it could be
simple statements like if you add any
two even numbers you've got another even
number so these are statements about an
infinite number of things which is
rather a critical point and how do you
prove things like that now is it
according to following some specific
logical system
well what girdle shows and Turing had a
very nice nicer way of doing it but what
Google showed is that given your system
of proof procedures and if you by
understanding what the system does if
you trust the results that says are true
if you test it on the theorem say is go
box check your world if it is suggests a
thing and if it comes out and says yes
done then you believe it and you believe
it because you've gone through all the
proof procedures and the accidents
involved in you're stuck that the first
one says yeah that's okay I trust that
one and next one yet mmm ah yeah that's
okay yes I see that one and so on until
you've totally convinced anything using
those methods if it says yes that's true
you believe it
then what girl does is he shows a
statement which absolutely clearly
constructed from this set of rules which
is a statement of the same kind about
numbers and this not this statement you
can see if you trust your system if
you're prepared to use your system to
get truths then you must trust this as
being true as well right so this
statement is true on the basis of your
same belief system as following the
rules and things you come out with so if
you trust the system screen as give you
any truths then you must believe the
statement yet at the same time you
demonstrate that it's not derive above
by the rules now how the hell do we know
it's true if you can't prove it if you
can't really it's that way yes you can
see it's true by means of the same
understandings that you have that the
procedures that you're accepting is
giving you proofs
so that I just I was blown over by this
when I saw it and I thought gosh this
means as far as I can make out that our
abilities to understand things are not a
computation no matter what it is now
because we can see truths that you know
our mind you get the result that our
minds are not going through a proof
procedure with in some form that's right
yes I mean you can you can add that
thing to the other one if you like and
say okay here's my new proof procedure
but that sort of cheating because that
wasn't what you started with how did you
know that other one was true and when
your things you're supposed to know a
true of the things that comes from some
algorithm and your head
and so what algorithm can that be if you
can you could supersede it now then I
started thinking about well I don't like
to think there's some mysterious I'm
goodness knows what if it comes from the
fairies or something which which gives
us insights I think that our brains are
constructed according to the same
physical laws as everything else in the
world
maybe if something subtle about why it's
organized but then I thought what about
well suppose it's Newtonian mechanics
well you could put it on a computer
there's a little bit of a issue here
because strictly speaking the laws that
we know are based on the continuum not
discreteness but this sort of feeling is
that if you had enough precision you're
not you're going to get close enough
that needs a bit more exploration but I
think I'm not going to argue for that I
think that's the fact that it's
continuum as opposed to discreteness I
don't think it's a big point it was
worth exploring that but that's not what
I thought okay what about special
relativity well it still calculations
like Newton's things what about
Maxwell's equations these continuous
things ways and so well yes same issue
about the discreteness but that's not
probably the real point you could put on
a computer and what about general
relativity again you could put on the
computer and we have really good
demonstration of this now with a lie
goes and this calculation but on a
computer absolutely I mean these
calculations have come from really
delicate
understandings and calculations which
should produce the signals that you
expect to see from black hole encounters
so we can certainly apply these
procedures to understand general
relativity now what about quantum
mechanics well you can evolve the
Schrodinger equation okay this is
difficult because you got all these new
degrees of freedom you should keep track
of - yeah but you could still put that
on a computer but then I remembered the
rax piece of chalk you see yeah but hmm
there's a gap and if what we act upon
when we're thinking and understanding
things that's the main thing a
concentrate on our understanding I would
argue is something which is not a
computable process and the only place I
could see where there's a relevant gap
in our physical understanding is in this
measurement process or the selection the
random part of quantum random part
quantum mechanics that's right so that's
where we don't have a proper theory so
the argument is that whatever is going
on in our heads when it's producing
conscious understandings conscious
feelings conscious whatever then that's
this kind of gap in our understanding I
mean this is probably too much to ask a
brief period of time but so how do we go
from the randomness to some kind of
understanding that goes beyond the
merely algorithmic well the argument
would be it's not really random okay it
looks random but that's because we
that's the level we're at at quantum
again there's something deeper going on
so there's a thumb on the scale the
collapse of the wavefunction to give us
some kind of insight into oh yes it's
the sort of opposite of some view that
people have that the collapse of the
wavefunction takes place when some
conscious observer sees it so this is
the opposite of that it's not that our
consciousness creates the collapse it's
the collapse that creates our
consciousness so the idea is that as I
wrote this book the emperor's new mind
where I I didn't know much about neuro
biology and so on I thought well I'll
learn about it and by the time I get to
the end of the book I'll see where
there's a place that you could have
quantum coherence at the level needed I
didn't wrote the book publishes words I
just made up something at the end which
I didn't really believe him and sent the
book out hoping that it would maybe
stimulate some young people to do
physics or maths or something most of
the letters I got from old [ __ ] people
but then I got one letter which was a
little different for both of these from
our friend Stuart here Stuart Hameroff
told me look you I think you might find
these structures more relevant to your
concerns than just neuron nerve
propagation which I thought it wasn't
that they were hope in hell of producing
preserving coherence because it disturbs
the environment and you get these
electric fields and stuff which churn
everything around unsure how do you keep
that quiet so Stuart in this letter
describe to me these little tubes nano
sized nanoscale tubes and I thought what
are these I mean I got lots of crazy
letters some people is this another one
they look pretty real in the pictures so
I check happen say yeah they're just my
ignorance was I didn't know about them
and so Stuart came off to Oxford where I
was at the time and we got together and
tried to make sense of what each other
was talking about and I mean one thing
that there is a lurking question here I
did have David Chalmers on the podcast
and we talked about the hard problem
versus the easy problem of consciousness
it from everything you just said it
sounds to me like what you're pointing
at or what Chalmers would call the easy
problems of consciousness and admittedly
no one thinks the easy problems are easy
some people think the hard problem is
impossible some people think it's easy
but yeah everyone thinks the easy
problems are hard do you think that this
way of thinking about quantum wave
function collapse in the brain would
help us understand the process of
experience the first bridge activeview
yeah I mean I have this short discussion
with David Chalmers I think after talk
I'd given us only about 10 seconds
discussions but see he was complaining
because I was saying
basically the view that Stuart and I
have is that whenever one of these
collapse processes takes place that's
where the state decides to be one or the
other when I say it decides you see this
sort of it gets decided yes what is it
you see that we call that is always
accompanied by a moment of proto
consciousness now you see proto
consciousness you think of that as the
building blocks out of which
consciousness is finally constructed it
doesn't have any purpose at that level
but it's the thing out of which
consciousness is built now David I think
then like this he thought it was still
not a solution of the hard problem
whether it is or not us right on your
point of view but it's saying okay here
is something which goes on in the
physical world out of which
consciousness is built and so it's a
point of view that experience so you say
there's a sort of there are many many
element of experience every time these
reductions take place but it's only
photo conscious it doesn't relate it to
anything else and doesn't have any
purposes it just does it and part of why
you're here in Southern California and I
get to talk to you is because you have a
new Institute does that right the
Penrose Institute yes
consciousness is going to be one of the
that was certainly one of the topics
absolutely no I I think I mean I went I
was approached by James Tague originally
I mean the idea of a bit scary and I
wasn't sure about it but it seems to me
here is an opportunity to explore things
where you know the mainstream is going
in another direction and one of the
obvious places is with the consciousness
issue and and sewers and a few people
take this point of view seriously and
here is a way of looking at it's not the
mainstream but it's a serious way of
looking at the problem which does have a
chance it seems to me of yielding some
real insights into what consciousness is
so just tell us a little bit about the
Penrose Institute it's in San Diego is
that right well it's not anywhere but
the state of mind right yeah it's sort
of spread out in various places but San
Diego is certainly well that was the
place it was initially supposed to be I
mean maybe it is it's not really based
anyway
it's kind of more of a concept rather
than having a clear location which you
know quantum mechanics you can have
things like perfectly compatible yes
exactly so what's the mission statement
of the Institute but I see III more or
less made it up but I can't remember it
the idea is to explore ideas which are
not mainstream but they have to be
things where they are experimentally
testable I I wanted to make sure about
that it's not a philosophy well that's
right and it's in danger of people might
say well it's flaky this is just some
ideas of you know who knows but they the
idea is they have to be things where you
could think they needn't be immediately
testable but pretty soon they've got to
be really within the range of techniques
and so but initially these were on the
consciousness thing or maybe things to
do what creativity is or something but I
thought most of my works on physics I
don't really do - I don't know much
biology so it's not really my main
interests and so I thought we need a
strong side on the physics side but
which is exploring these things which
are a little offbeat in the sense of not
too many people do it so things like the
collapse of the wavefunction was an
important one and I asked Yvette Fuentes
who's somebody I knew who works she
works on unconventional approaches to
gravitational wave detection and that's
what I knew about so use bose-einstein
condensates which is completely on a
different scale from LIGO but it struck
me that there's a lot of promise in that
idea because these bose-einstein
condensates are very the most quantum
mechanical thing you can think of more
or less and they're practically absolute
zero so you're looking at things which
which can be really isolated from
disturbance from the outside and not
only add long discussions with her also
about how you might use these things for
the collapse of the wave function so
this is actually the major project it's
it's being done in Nottingham in England
at the moment because that's where her
post she was in Vienna
when I was getting her interested in
this and so she has a team of people
working in Nottingham and one of the
projects they main projects they're
really concerned with this looking at
these bose-einstein condensation
condensates and whether you can see
whether the collapse of the wave
function takes place in a measurable way
and which is objective not something
that depends on somebody looking at it
and really the system itself does this
or that in in a time scale which is
consistent with with the sort of
proposal that I was putting forward well
you know as a scientist it's always good
to be correct to say things that are
true but also at which you certainly
have done but it's also something to be
said when you're able to inspire and
provoke people into doing interesting
things and looking into things in
slightly new ways that's very much the
case yes and the hope is of course yes
to get other people who might be
interested in exploring some of these
ideas and taking them seriously and and
you've got a lot of things named after
you along the way which is pretty good
all right Roger Penrose it's been a
great pleasure thanks so much for being
on the fight thank you great pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]